I'm bulletproof you're dead superhero
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie happy Labor
Day if you guys are celebrating it we
got a new Shazam trailer so let's break
it down we got a little bit more of a
look at dr. sivana played by Mark Strong
funny to see him show up after being in
Green Lantern so long ago you also may
have noticed some of the jump cuts
during this trailer like they're
obviously cutting together a bunch of
different scenes so like during the
convenience store they walk out with a
bunch of sodor color which is a nice
easter egg from DC Comics but then right
after that there's a jump cut and he
says hey I'm a superhero and he's
holding all this different junk food
that's probably just because this is a
much longer scene and he walks back in
and gets a bunch of different junk food
after he walks out with the coal like oh
we need some junk food in addition to
the Sodor kohler there's all those
Easter eggs for a Man of Steel there's
the Batarang from Batman vs Superman
I've already explained where some of
those came from like the bullet that he
has in there is actually a bullet that
Batman fired at Superman
during Batman V Superman that some but
apparently just went around collecting
all those shells then sold them on eBay
and because Freddie Freeman is like the
superhero fanboy like the Justice League
fanboy within the context of this movie
he's the guy that collects all that kind
of stuff Billy Batson when we meet him
is kind of jaded so I think that once he
gets his powers he slowly learns to be a
part of this family and if you read the
Geoff Johns new 52 Shazam run then you
probably recognize all these scenes they
collected it later on but Shazam new 52
origin story was all about the seven
deadly sins dr. sivana in releasing
Black Adam so I'm wondering if they're
building towards a similar Black Adam
reveal towards the end of this movie so
we'll explain what's going on with the
seven deadly sins in dr. sivana because
he is the main villain of this movie but
really it's kind of the seven deadly
sins if you're not a big comic book
reader we actually saw the Greek gods
during the Wonder Woman movie imagine
they would have evil counterparts that's
kind of who the seven deadly sins are
the weird thing about the Shazam
character is that he's sort of this pan
magical character that sort of crosses
over with all the other DC magical care
like Constantine Wonder Woman because of
what's going on with the gods dr. fate
Zatanna pretty much anybody that wields
magic inside the DC Universe
because the wizard Shazam has a seat on
the Council of eternity and they're the
people that rule over all magical things
so anytime they need to sanction someone
or someone goes crazy like Black Adam
they usually get involved when he gives
Billy Batson his power say my name's
Shazam that's him passing his seat on
the council of eternity to Billy
but because Billy is a little kid he
totally doesn't get that so this first
big story of him getting his powers is
all about learning just the mechanics of
how those work in the fact that he now
has this greater responsibility to
protect magic like you reread this panel
here your powers are vast beyond your
flight and strength and spells you can
weave there are so many like he can
actually weave spells he doesn't know
how to do it yet but he can cast spells
the same way that Zatanna or Constantine
would you must learn watch over them
your family as I should have so his
family is obviously talking about the
foster family like Freddy Freeman and
the other members of the Marvel family
but also sort of the magical community
the movies a little bit more focused on
this foster family though like they're
not gonna try and get too complicated
with that like I'm not expecting too
many other magical people to pop up in
the movie once they introduce it though
it's totally fair game because they're
still working on that Justice League
dark movie but like you see Billy here
he realizes my family you know who my
parents are this is still before he's
embraced that foster family like is he
slowly starting to learn about pretty
Freeman you have that funny line it gets
real Game of Thrones around here most of
you probably already realized even if
you haven't read this comic though this
particular panel here where the wizard
says family is what it can be not what
it should be that is your secret spell
your ultimate power that's foreshadowing
for him sharing his power with the rest
of the Marvel family so that they all
get their powers because even though
black Adam was a big part of this origin
story and he's not gonna be in this
first movie it was all about Black Adam
trying to release the seven deadly sins
in taking control of all magic in the
world so you have to imagine that what
they've done with the Shazam movie is
that this
have swapped that for more pure dr.
sivana storyline in the filmmaker has
already said that the way they sort of
wrote him into the movie is that he was
actually at one time one of the
candidates that the wizard decided to
choose to accept his power but it failed
like he was trying to impress his own
family dr. sivana as a young person
his father was abusive he was never able
to please him so it turned him evil and
eventually he sought power to just
destroy everything like imagine an
Incredibles version of Syndrome like he
starts out as a little kid really
idealistic but gets super jaded and that
eventually turns into this big huge
villain that tries to use the power of
the seven deadly sins which are trapped
in the rock of eternity so I think
they're trying to be relatively true to
dr. sivanna's back story in the comics
while also incorporating sort of this
alternate version of billy's origin
story that went totally sideways which
is also a little bit like black adams
origin story so i don't think they're
trying to borrow too much from black
adam because they will actually be doing
a Shazam versus black adam movie just
not the very first stories that they
tell because what happens is is dr.
sivana wants to use black adam's power
for his own personal gain so he frees
him from imprisonment he's been in there
for about a thousand years so he comes
out and then it becomes sort of a billy
batson
versus black adam in dr. sivana who have
teamed up but then by the end it becomes
the entire suzanne family versus black
adam so we think they pushed off that
part of the story where dr. sivana seeks
out black adam's tomb frees him and then
they team up maybe there's a
post-credits scene where at the end he
seeks out black adam and even if the
rock doesn't appear on screen in costume
you still get a bit of a teaser even
though I'm also expecting sort of a
Superman more happy teaser with Billy
Batson because Superman is invoked so
much in this movie but let me know in
the comments what do you guys think of
this so far and the idea that this sort
of splitting up that new 52 Geoff Johns
origin story into two movies in the
first half will be all about explaining
who the seven deadly sins are who dr.
sivana is why it's important for Billy
to learn that secret spell that his
family is his real superpower they
become the comic book Shazam family so
that in the second movie when you get
the Black Adam
and he's released they all fight him
together but I think a lot of that
second movie will just depend on how
this first movie does I think it'll do
okay so I don't think there's any worry
there I think we're really just curious
to see what they're gonna do with the
rocks Black Adam character and even as
they still said that they're gonna make
a solo movie that'll set up his origin
I'm guessing that that's gonna be set
during the past and they'll stick to
this new 52 story where he's imprisoned
at the end of that and then woken up
during the Shazam sequel but if you're
wondering about Aquaman's stuff I think
they're gonna be dropping new trailers
sometime in October definitely by the
time we get to November so there'll be a
whole bunch of Marvel trailers dropping
between Captain Marvel and Aquaman and
Shazam really soon what'll probably
happen in my DC movie videos that I do
for the rest of the years I'll do
Aquaman ticket giveaways just because
that's the next movie that's coming up
but if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos click
here to rewatch the Aquaman trailer and
click here for the new venom trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you